[Music]
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to take your life on right
this is my guide to cooking with spice
adding big gutsy flavors using spices at
the beginning of cooking and then simply
letting the dish slow cook is a
brilliant way of getting maximum flavor
with minimum effort
my first recipe melts in the mouth and
because the oven does most of the work
it's a cinch to make slow cooked fiery
lamb cooking's all about being bold and
adventurous and this dish is exciting
because it's slowly cooked and the
longer it Cooks the more flavors on it
becomes
marinating the lamb first chillers we're
going to use a mixture of red and green
take off the tops
and just slice
in
garlic
crushed
don't worry about chopping these ultra
fine just
get it in there cooking for up to three
hours everything sort of Blends and
almost sort of
pures itself together
smoked paprika it goes brilliantly well
with the chilies two teaspoons in a
touch of dried oregano
some little cumin seeds the blend and
the fragrance that they give out is
extraordinary they release a little oil
as well it helps to tenderize the lamb
Touch of salt
pepper
cinnamon
that sort of sweetens up the lamb
olive oil
just a tablespoon and the olive oil
helps to sort of stick all those
wonderful spices to the lamb Chomp in
just start really rubbing at this stage
you can leave the lamb to marinade for
anything from half an hour to overnight
a lamb with spices to really penetrate
the meat giving amazing results when you
tuck in delicious vegetables carrots and
onions and that's it sliced
cigarette slicing vegetables for
braising is not getting too thin you
slice the onions too thin they burn
you've got that horrible Char taste on
that slow braised braising it's just a
chef's term that means cooking in liquid
on a low heat making the meat incredibly
moist and beautifully tender so the
secret of braising is having a really
nice thick
durable pan get that nice and hot
Touch of olive oil
lamin hold the bone because you're in
control then into the pan
you want that white fat to start
rendering so it'll add more fat
therefore making it a lot more
flavoursome as it braises
Chillers
cinnamon
in mix that up
and don't be scared you're not burning
this you're sort of searing the lamb
shanks and this is the important part
right at the very beginning we're
getting the color on the lamb which
washes off as it braises in the oven so
be generous with that color
vegetables in
wow and then a couple of Baileys
so now you lift the lamb up
and get the lamb
sat on top of the vegetables
now the glaze the pan with red wine
the glazing beans that you'll you clean
the bottom of the pan and you're getting
that amazing flavor washed off and
lifted up into that sauce it can really
transform that dish always delays then
bring to the boil and cook for about 10
minutes to reduce the wines reduced down
by half now for the stock
bring that stock back up to the ball and
then into the oven now don't cover it
when you cover it all the condensation
comes off the lid your lamb becomes gray
all this effort and that exciting spice
gets washed away no lid and in the oven
for three hours
I slow cook on a low heat of 160 degrees
gives the spices time to work and
transform the meat so it's
mouth-wateringly tender now
look at those
out on to a plate you can just see that
meat sliding down
juicy and crabby tender grab it by the
the shank rolling around that rich
delicious sauce
look at that
and get your sauce nice
beautiful just get some mint don't chop
it just pick that fresh mint and let it
snow and there you go a very spicy
delicious melting in the mouth lamb
shank amazing
[Music]
to get the most out of your spices
there's only one piece of kit that you
need pestle and water I mean they look
fantastic and it's essential for any
good kitchen these things are so
versatile these ancient kitchen tools
are perfect for everything from pestos
to dressings and cost them around 15
quid
used to grind spices and you'll max out
on Flavor get perfect textures and
always be totally in control make sure
you've got a nice large circumference of
the bowl
so you can grind away the heavier the
more durable they are the more
confidence it gives you when you're
pounding and there's almost a way of
confirming homemade hand pounded
grab yourself a pestle of mortar and
soon you'll be spicing with ease
[Music]
[Applause]
spices are a brilliant way to add an
extra layer and a depth of complexity to
any dish learning to use them properly
will really improve your cooking here
are three more of my super simple spice
recipes to get you going
[Music]
first up a very easy chili and spice
white bait
start with the spice coating
toast Szechuan peppercorns and coriander
seeds in a hot dry pan to release their
flavors
[Music]
add chili flakes and grind the pestle
and water to make a fiery fine powder
combined with plain flour season and mix
[Music]
add olive oil to a hot pan
coat white bait in the spicy flour mix
then fry
white bait are an oily fish that are
healthy delicious and cooking minutes
[Music]
once golden they're done
fantastic with garlic mayonnaise or a
simple squeeze of lemon
[Music]
ready in under 10 minutes chili and
spiced white bait and easy simple spicy
dish
[Music]
my next amazingly aromatic recipe is
roasted squash hummus
[Music]
but with my take on razal hanoud a
classic Moroccan spice blend
in a dry pan toast Cinnamon cloves
coriander
fenugreek and fennel seeds
then add mustard seeds and cumin
when the seeds start to pop they're
ready
at paprika and grind into a fine powder
for the hummus peel and chopped
butternut squash
put on a baking tray and add garlic
simply bashed and chopped Ginger
drizzle with olive oil season and
sprinkle over the spice mix
then roast in a hot oven for half an
hour until soft
allowed to cool and place in a blender
at tahini a Nutty paste made from sesame
seeds cooked chickpeas a dash of lemon
juice
and a drizzle of olive oil
flits into a luxuriously creamy and
textured
spices toasted for maximum flavor
amazing roasted squash hummus
my final deliciously spicy dishes
curry spice sweet corn soup
[Music]
first The Fragrant curry paste
roast coriander and cumin seeds until
aromatic
then grind adding crushed garlic chili
powder turmeric and finely chopped
Ginger
foreign
together with olive oil to form a thick
paste
for the soup fry finely chopped onions
in olive oil
add the curry paste and cook to release
the flavors
add cubed potatoes
chicken stock
and season
when the potato has softened stir in
creamed corn
[Music]
then add whole sweet corn kernels with
some of the juices
and transfer to a blender and Blitz
until smooth
for texture add more whole sweet corn
[Music]
and it's ready to serve
wonderfully satisfying curried spiced
sweet corn soup that packs an amazingly
aromatic punch
three more stunning recipes that make
cooking with spice simple
incredible
[Music]
and back to my ultimate cookery course
this is my guide to cooking with spice
next up my shopping guide to buying
spices
[Music]
buy my spice I only want the best and it
always pays to get expert advice Burger
has been selling every spice Under the
Sun in London's Notting Hill for over 20
years so she really knows what she's
talking about I love supposed to smell
the texture
texture spices are so versatile
something very very simple can be really
transformed into something really
delicious with thousands of aromatic
ingredients on a shelves if it smells
good she sells it if you're buying
spices buy them whole then you can try
roast them grind them when you need them
and then they will release the essential
oils whole spices you've been kid for
years give them a good bushing wine
bottle with your rolling pin or whatever
and you see there is still a Roma and
you can taste it you smell it then it's
fine
there's four main spouses one is sweet
one is sour one is bitter and one is hot
this is cinnamon and that is really a
great example of a sweet spice when you
buy cinnamon quill like this you have to
check that you have loads of different
layers in here then you can either grind
this or you'd break a piece off I mean
this doesn't smell of anything now
but if you roll it in your hand just
quickly like this
and then you smell it again this is just
unbelievable if you have spaghetti
bolognese put a pinch of cinnamon in it
to bring out the flavor
this is one of those
really special spices sour like a lemon
but it has a salty aftertaste I use this
anywhere for marinades to salad you
haven't left unless you tried it a great
example for a bit of spice would
actually be a turmeric this is actually
a root it grows in the ground like
ginger use it very very sparingly about
that much well actually color you a
curry or a rice dish wonderful yellow
watch your fingers you get really yellow
fingers from it and then we come to the
hot spices one spice that I couldn't
miss and that is Hungarian paprika
paprika is the powdery form of a bell
pepper what makes the Hungarian paprika
different is that they actually cried on
Vineyards it's sort of between the vines
it has a sweetness and it has a
sharpness to it I have it in ice cream I
have it on fish I have it everywhere
burger spot on about the power of spices
to transform dishes whether Savory or
sweet here's my quick guide to the
spices I use most
[Music]
spice I couldn't do without always buy a
whole and grind yourself so you get the
freshest flavor
cardamom these pods come in green or
black types and have a fantastic Spicy
Sweet Taste brilliant for everything
from curries to rice dishes and puddings
coriander these citrusy seeds are
perfect whole in pickles or grind to use
in fragrant stews and soups
cumin a Savory Spice that's pungent and
nutty it's great in marinade for
delicious Meat and Fish
then cinnamon sweetly fragrant and great
with apples or in cakes
and Nutmeg warm and spicy it's delicious
in a vegetable sauce finely saffron
these sweet strands Infuse a brilliant
bright red color and are great in
risottos and even though it's more
expensive than gold a pinch goes a long
long way store your spices properly and
they'll last for years you keep it
airtight in a tin or in a glass chair in
your cupboard
don't be scared of spices like an
aftershave or a perfume you have to
select it yourself it has to fit in with
your taste and with your kitchen
supermarkets and good local shops sell
an amazing array of different spices so
there's no excuse for not being
adventurous be bold find what you like
and spice up your cooking
like all chefs I love the challenge of
transforming classic recipes giving them
a new twist to make them modern and
vibrant
keep old dishes fresh and exciting it's
great to get spicy
my next recipe is a time-honored British
classic but with addition of spices it's
given a new lease of Life fragrant spice
rice pudding I love cooking with spices
but you don't have to just cook Savory
dishes using aromatics and spices across
desserts takes your puddings to a
completely different level
first off our spices this is a fresh
vanilla pod fragrant and packed full of
flavor use the back of the knife and
flatten it that removes all those little
seeds off the skin of the vanilla pod
take your knife slice down the middle
and then when you open that up the smell
is incredible
take the tip of the knife and you scrape
inside and look all those seeds dying to
come out that is incredible there are
thousands of seeds still ingrained to
the Pod so put them in to the casserole
cardamom powerful spicy say two little
pods place your knife on top
lightly crack them cracking the cardamom
pods helps release all the amazing
flavor cloves because that kind of
aniseed flavor with a lot of depth
one two three cinnamon stick
snap and in
just smelling that level of fragrance
you can imagine what the rice pudding is
going to taste of turn on the heat
lightly toast those spices just a couple
of seconds and what's going to happen is
just going to sort of enhance those
spices in a way that it just draws out
an even more powerful fragrance coconut
milk in
sugar two tablespoons
milk
and then a couple of tablespoons of
cream
bring it slowly to the boil to allow the
flavors to infuse and this rice pudding
reminds me of my time in India where I
got really into that chai tea fragrance
because it was just so delicious and so
comforting
take a lime
in
the lime just cuts through the richness
of the coconut gives it that nice little
bit of acidity because fantastically
well with a cinnamon and that fresh
vanilla
nice have a taste
now let's come up to the boil give it a
nice little clean around the outside
and in with the rice
use 200 grams of pudding rice don't wash
it beforehand because the starch helps
thicken the rice pudding in the oven
and just turn that down to a light
simmer and the pudding rice starts to
open up and it absorbs all that coconut
vanilla
cardamom clove and cinnamon bring up to
the ball gently and cook it out for
three to five minutes
boiling it rapidly the rice opens up and
it goes into mush we want to keep that
nice texture of that sort of fragrant
rice pudding on a gentle simmer
next a little luxury
I'm going to show you how I take this
simple delicious aromatic rice pudding
to a completely different level here's
what I do take two egg yolks separate
them
now give that a really nice whisk
two nice tablespoons of mascarpone
cheese
whisk that into the egg yolks
[Music]
just as nice and smooth it's almost like
finishing the rice pudding in a
delicious custard turn off the gas add
that
into the rice pudding what happens it
starts to enrich and really thicken this
rice pudding and takes it to a
completely different level
the rice is still not cooked started to
go nice and soft you can just see how
it's opening up
but look it's like Rich aromatic lava
bubbling away
finally green more citrus zest the lime
on top
roasted caramelized lime zest on top of
a rice pudding
is phenomenal
then put it in the oven 15 minutes at
200 degrees to finish cooking the rice
and develop the intensely aromatic
flavors
[Music]
look at that
an incredibly fragrant rice pudding how
beautiful does that look
spices are a brilliant way of helping
classic dishes come alive
I'll guarantee you'll never ever have
had a rice pudding like this before
[Music]
next my trick is the trays and kitchen
tips
[Music]
[Applause]
first how to zest the lemon
the important part is not to zest any of
the pith watch the following technique
and I'll show you how
we've got these original graters really
important when we use this is the fine
zester not the big rough one not the one
for slicing and not the other one for
grating this little one here onto a
plate because it's always easier to lift
off on the plate than it is the board
and the most important thing about
zesting a lemon is nice long strokes but
twisting the lemon round every time we
go down we twist
same with the orange and same with the
lime
little tap
if you go too far let me just show you
look you've got that white bitter pith
that destroys the wonderful
zesty flavor and look that's what we're
looking for there this really nice
vibrant lemon zest
delicious
garlic is a key ingredient in so many
spicy dishes my tip for finally chopping
a minson is add a pinch of salt for
abrasion which helps break the fibers of
the garlic down for a much better result
for getting the most out of root Ginger
simply remove the skin using a teaspoon
it's easier than using a knife and you
can get around the tricky bits or just
keep the skin on and give it a good wash
[Music]
never throw out vanilla pods there's a
ton of flavor left in the skin stick
inside jars of sugar and leave to infuse
great to sprinkle on cakes biscuits or
porridge
when grinding up spices if you have any
left over you can store in an airtight
jar for up to two months great for a
spicy kick to have at your fingertips
this is my guide to amazing home-cooked
street food classics
Seafood gets his name because it's
cooked and eaten on the streets from the
Hawker markets in Asia to the New York
hot dog stands there are some great
chefs out there serving seriously
delicious food that you can eat on the
go
foreign
is a special mix of fantastic flavors
from around the world beef tacos with
Wasabi Mayo
the great thing about street food is
anything goes the Only Rule is they've
got to be really fast and really tasty
now these tacos makes a Mexican and
Japanese flavors into a delicious meaty
mouthful
first off give that pan really nice and
hot these are sirloin steaks
sear it in the pan with all that fat on
I'll add flavor
salt and pepper
a couple tablespoons of olive oil in
pan nice and hot
hold of the steak
and lay it in always lay away
[Music]
a little shake and it stops the steak
from sticking we're looking for color
if it sticks it's gonna burn
while the steaks are cooking I can go
with my super quick marinade now
two tablespoons of
meat soup paste that's a fermented
soybean that gives a really nice sort of
Rich sweetness
tablespoon of sugar a couple tablespoons
rice wine that gives it a really nice
fengary kick a couple tablespoons of
olive oil
salt and pepper
I'm looking for a nice sort of thick
Rich marinade
mayonnaise done it's time to turn the
steaks
[Music]
it's all the pan
into the other steaks it's a little
based all we're doing every time is just
adding more and more flavor
take your tongs and sort of lift the
steak on its back and really melt all
that fat down
off of the gas
take them out just take your knife
feel that fat there just slice that off
I don't want any of that
now
in
to the marinade
useful
tacos are one of Mexico's most popular
Street Foods they've been made from beef
poor chicken or fish and are loaded up
with amazing sauces and spices
now I want something sort of pickly
cabbage these are Chinese cabbages slice
it in half
and look at it really crisp and really
tasty
I'm gonna slice that into quarters
and then just shred it and take your
time
think of cabbage here and you think
you're sort of braised
overcooked cabbage nothing worse
but I'll tackle you want freshness
a little season of chili flakes
they sort of discreetly give it a little
bit of heat
a little touch of rice wine vinegar if
you haven't got that fresh lemon juice
small drop of toasted sesame seed oil
give that
and really good mix
now I need something to sort of bring it
together we take some Wasabi paste very
hot very spicy a sort of thumbnail size
I'm gonna mix that
with a couple of tablespoons of
mayonnaise
and give that a really good mix
these are basic corn tortilla the trick
is
to sort of color them
and then shape them actually place it
on
the gas ring
using tongs
so it's not to burn yourself
you can also toast your tacos in a
frying pan from there
I'm just gonna place it
on the rolling pin literally 30 seconds
as it cools down the great thing about
serving tacos is people can fill them
themselves just the way they want them
cabbage just squeeze out wet marinade
it's a nice rustic Little Mountain
very nice
on
wait to see how soft and delicious and
almost sort of melting in the mouth
texture we've got on this amazing
sirloin
still got that really nice
see ya around the outside
just nice and pink in the middle
start off with my crispy shell back of
the spoon with the Wasabi mayonnaise
inside taco
just sprinkle that delicious
pickled cabbage
and then just start lining my attacker
with three or four slices
touch more
am I spicy
Mayo
that is how I'd make
the perfect attacker
when you want comfort food quick fast
food Classics always deliver here are
three more of my street food favorites
all super easy but still put the Gourmet
into grab and go
this street food dish packs a wonderful
Indian influence subtly spiced chicken
wrap
[Music]
grab a mortar and pestle to make a spicy
marinade for the chicken crack open
cardamom pods and add ground ginger
coriander
cinnamon
grated nutmeg
clove of garlic
fresh coriander
lemon juice
olive oil
and seasoned
now pulverize to form a paste
[Music]
pour over the chicken thighs and leave
some marinade for up to two hours
[Music]
the cook griddle on a high heat to get
wonderfully charred meat
[Music]
once the chicken is cooked warm through
tortilla wraps on the same griddle
then simply slice your chicken
[Music]
and put your wrap together
top with shredded cabbage
[Applause]
chopped spring onion
and your favorite chili sauce
[Music]
ready in 20 minutes sticky succulent and
utterly Moorish spiced chicken wrap
you'll find my next fast food Classic
All Over America tasty chili dogs
[Music]
for super quick and easy beef chili add
chopped onions to hot olive oil and cook
until soft
then add chopped garlic
a teaspoon of cumin seeds and stir to
release their lovely aromatic flavor
next chili powder
[Music]
turn up the heat and break beef mince
into the pan
Brown and seasoned
add tomato puree and cook through
next I dug a spicy Worcestershire sauce
chopped in tomatoes
dried oregano
add a Sprinkle of sugar
[Music]
Frankfurter or prep word sausages
bung in a bun
and simply top with a spicy beef chili
easy and irresistible a dog worth
crossing the street for
my third street food inspired recipe is
Vietnamese style baguette with beef
[Music]
start slicing sirloin steak into strips
then simply marinate in soy sauce the
salty
and runny honey the sweet
and leave for up to two hours
then thread your marinated beef strips
onto skewers
and pan fry in hot olive oil
for the topping which adds a lovely sour
contrast great carrot and simply leave
to pickle in rice vinegar
next make the easy dressing simply
deseed and chop a chili
add caster sugar and lime juice
and a glug of fish sauce
slice the baguette
when lovely and brown the marinated
steak skewers are done remove and add
top with a pickled carrot
add cool sliced cucumber drizzle over
the spicy dressing
and to finish it off add coriander
leaves
simple to make but complex in flavor
absolutely delicious
[Music]
stunning recipes from the streets to
your home guaranteed to take food on the
run to a whole new level and so simple
to do
[Music]
you don't need to spend a fortune on
masses of kitchen equipment here's my
quick guide to another cooking essential
pan
for me one of my favorites why because
it's so versatile whether you're searing
the most amazing rack of lamb cooking
duck breasts sauteing chicken or even a
quick omelette or even find an egg
all in one
look for an oven proof frying pan with a
metal handle if you want to cook like
pros by finishing off your dish in the
oven or under a Hot Grill just don't
forget when you take it out the handle
will be hot if you can get a high
quality non-stick one with a thick heavy
base which will distribute the heat
evenly
brilliant
[Music]
welcome back to my ultimate cookery
course
next on my guide to Street Food
I'll be whipping up an indulgent finger
licking treat that is amazing
but first
like any passionate Chef I want the best
ingredients I can find whether it's for
savory
or sweet dishes next up my guide to
buying chocolates
[Music]
chocolate gives you such an instant hit
it's well worth knowing about the good
stuff
and who's better to ask than
award-winning Alchemist of the sweetest
kind Paul Young even when I don't want
to think about it I'm thinking about it
his Cutting Edge approach to chocolate
making has won him accolades around the
world
so when you're out shopping the best way
is to look at your chocolate bar look on
the back and look at the percentage that
gives you how much cocoa is in the bar
and the more cocoa the more Rich
intoxicating flavor
so the most exciting bit is tasting
chocolate
good quality fine chocolate should have
that clean snap bite a piece off and
crunch it in your teeth
but stop chewing
let it melt
move it around the mouth and you'll find
that by letting it melt
even dark chocolate that you've had
before that seems quite bitter won't be
when you're too quickly it releases
tannin it releases all the bitterness in
the chocolate letting it melt it's
smoother and return you get all the
flavor and most excitingly is it
releases something into the brain called
dopamine which makes you feel good
and that's how you get addicted to real
chocolate
is not just an addictive treat it's an
amazing ingredient here's my take on
which kind to use for what
chocolate with its sweet vanilla taste
is perfect used as a dipping or pouring
sauce with fresh fruit or frozen berries
for a quick dessert
chocolate is great for family friendly
puddings and treats like quick baked
cakes or melt it onto homemade Crepes or
waffles
dark chocolate is Rich and intense I
like using 70 cocoa stuff use it for ice
creams that really pack a punch
100 pure cocoa has a very powerful
intense taste and only the real
chocolate Geeks eat it straight and
remember chocolate isn't just for sweet
dishes for the famous Mexican mole sauce
this is the one to grab
is there anything better than chocolate
they say sex but I've done totally
overrated
chocolate is the key ingredient in my
favorite sweet fast food dishes which at
their best are always irresistible
instant and utterly satisfying
so when you want an indulgent chocolate
hit my next recipe will be right up your
alley malt chocolate donuts street food
is all about satisfying your Cravings
these Donuts are Sweet Sticky and
absolutely delicious
first off we're gonna make the dough
this dough takes a bit of time but it's
really exciting I'm heating all of the
milk with the sugar this yeast
easy to get hold of and when you make
fresh donuts you need fresh yeast adding
some of the warm milk to the yeast will
activate it which will help the dough to
rise just half
give that a quick whisk
the sugars dissolved in the milk the
fresh yeast disintegrates instantly
set the yeast mixture to one side while
it does its job
to start the main dough mix I'm adding
half the butter to the remaining milk
that gives the dough a nice silkiness I
want it light
so melt the butter into the milk flour
into a sieve that helps to make the
dough nice and smooth and you know what
when you've got a smooth dough it sort
of Rises evenly
add a pinch of salt and two egg yolks
pour in the warm milk and melted butter
don't start over mixing it
and you have a mix the dough of a donut
it gets really tight you're not going to
let it aerate yeast in
nice and warm I love that smell now I'm
looking for a sort of elasticy texture
just dropping off the spoon
nice flower of the board
the dough out
lightly sprinkle touch more flour and
just pull it over and push in and every
time you're sort of turning it almost
like you're turning the dough into
itself the dough should just sort of
relax
I should be sticking to your fingers now
it's just nice and pliable set that in a
nice clean bowl a little sprinkling
flour in there so as it starts to rise
it doesn't stick
cover that with the same film
leave the dough to rise in a warm place
for 60 to 90 minutes until it's doubled
in size this stage is called proving now
whilst that's proving get a panel
for the chocolate filling or ganache
pour 500 mL of double cream into a
saucepan and add honey
[Music]
bring the mixture to a gentle boil
traditionally we've always put Jam in
there but chocolate and donuts wow to
die for
cream
now give that a good mix
the butter elevates the ganache into a
really nice shiny chocolate coat
look at that whoa give it a really nice
whisk
the whistling gives it that aerated
texture to the ganache you're just
lightening the load a little bit
wow nice
chocolate filling done put it in the
fridge to cool then it's time to gently
roll out the dough
just let it roll naturally
about a centimeter and a half in depth
slice
one
two
place them on it's your tray and let
them rise again
once the donors have had 30 to 40
minutes to rise it's time to shallify
them in a pan-filled one-third full with
hot vegetable oil
risen but look there's sort of like
little pockets of air
right here we go
place these in nice and carefully
four Maxima if there's too many in the
pan the oil will go cold and the donuts
will come out soggy
whatever peaceful
[Music]
they're gonna come out into some sugar
mixed with some malt powder 50 50.
how do you tell they're actually cooked
in the center
app on top should be Hollow
in
just sprinkle
The Malt
and the sugar
shake off
the excess I get so excited every time I
make donuts now
look at those beauties
these are delicious eaten as they are
but the ganache is going to be the icing
on the cake
Piping Bag
peel the bag over your hands don't
forget to pop the nozzle in
I want the texture
almost like a little liquid inside so
I'm going to pipe them when they're a
little bit warm hopefully you've got
that burst of magic operation donut
lift up
the donut
squeeze push in and fill
just to start seeing that chocolate
coming out
sit that back down
nice
set them on there I've got a little bit
heavier and we all know why
nice that one's got my name on it
[Music]
that is amazing
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips
starting with how to do your steak the
way you want it I want to cut my steak
rare So by touching the steak I want the
same feedback as it is on the inside of
my thumb that's rare
as it starts to cook it gets a lot
firmer medium is there semi-firm with a
slight resistance well done is there
rare a great tip for getting meat or
fish to cook faster is to score it which
allows the heat to penetrate quicker
this also allows mayonnaise to be
absorbed more deeply
stain-free Tupperware
coat it thinly with oil which acts as a
barrier between plastic and food
so easy to make your own chili Sherry to
using quick stir fries or sauces take
450 mL of dry sherry such as Fino and
using a funnel pour into a sterilized
bottle
five whole Thai chilies seal with a cork
or lid and leave to infuse for a couple
of weeks
my tip for using any discarded chili
seeds is plant them to grow yourself
some new Chili Peppers plant in an
eggshell or seedling trays start them
indoors and move outside when they're
ready
[Music]
Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stay your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better Chef many of
these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking